yo bootle Kev podcast special guest here
he just dropped his this is his debut
album yes
sir the truth is in my eyes truth is in
my eyes I'd like to point out this is
very highly anticipated thank you for
bringing me a physical copy for show man
guarantee you you're the [__] man
people aren't doing these no more so and
this is legit [__] come on
man some some people do a CD but it's
like see you don't got the book see this
is the full you got the whole this is
vintage bro yeah man this is fire um
first of all before we like get into the
specifics of the album what I noticed
that you're doing which I think is
actually smart these days is you can't
go to Spotify for this album no man you
got to only cop this on big hit no.com
you feel me yeah so what was cuz
obviously for people who don't know like
if you get a million streams it's like
$3,700 which is pretty wild for being
honest um but if people like what what
what was the inspiration for you to you
know make people buy the album like
actually spend money on the
album I mean that's you know that's the
Mastermind hit you know what I'm saying
hereit boy so we just basically just
said [__] it just ball hogging just
doing us uh we lose a draw and uh like
it or love it yeah you know what I'm
saying type situation we just creating
good music
and uh and pushing Full Speed Ahead with
it you know what I'm saying the album's
been out um a few days what has been the
response and how has how has this
business model worked out so far oh it's
it's A1 man it's it's all booming it's
they fans is tapping in they they coping
the magazines they coping the shirts
Truth for M shirts going free shirts yep
well I'm glad well I'm glad that you
guys are doing it this way because like
I feel like something has to give for
like kind of like currently how artists
are compensated for their art you know
what I'm saying yeah I feel it my [__]
like n doing [__] for free it's really
what it is ain't nobody in in no other
game is doing [__] for free you can't go
to the to the man and and get a brick
[__] on ass my [__] tell [__] I'm I
got you later n just doing that [__] man
and dudes is really like devaluing you
know the game like it's it's it's really
just it's [__] the game up for you um
talk about because you and ever since
you got out this this last go round I
feel like you and your son have just
been in your bag like I mean it's been
crazy to watch just kind of like the
buzz that You' generated just
immediately the quality of records that
you were putting out on his [__] I mean
um the visuals have been there I know
you guys celebrated you guys shot one of
one of your videos uh was shot at my
club in Arizona he was out there with
all my bottle girls disgusting turned up
I loved it for sure AZ shout out AZ my
[__] um but this album man like um you
know it is it is a highly anticipated
album so you know for you like uh kind
of give me like the rundown of just how
you feel about this man finally getting
it off your chest it's got to feel good
with so many roadblocks that have come
up in your life and you know we we could
have got this album a decade ago yeah
you know yeah yep yeah for sure but you
know it's like a process man in the
building process and the learning
process and just now just got to
capitalize and you know and uh push Full
Speed Ahead man and uh you know make it
make sense you know for I'm I'm like
just all I know right now that's all I'm
doing I like a full-time rapper for real
yeah I ain't out there grinding like one
foot in one foot out like my [__] Benny
say that's real [__] you know what I'm
saying that's what I was doing last time
too and it [__] wasn't working I feel
like anybody who does the one foot out
one foot anything is it's there's like
an expiration date on that we see it
every almost every time moment at any
given moment you might get pulled over
with a gun you might there's so many
like little things that could go wrong
every day K or you might kill a [__]
anything you know what I'm saying it's
like yeah it's like you might as well
Focus so like for you like um talk to me
about like uh is there going to be any
sort of opportunity for the generic fan
to just stream this one day or is it
just like hey this is only going to be
something you could buy yeah it's like a
piece of art yeah yeah it's it's some
art right now I'm not really sure how
they doing it maybe later they feel like
they know might put streaming out or
whatever but right now we ball hogging
and we on to the next it's like this is
done so I know we got to push this but
we like we still creating music man we
just every day oh the work ethic over
there at hit spot is it's just it's just
nonstop I'm sure you probably already
got another album ready I got 10 albums
that's what I'm saying like 10 albums
ready man so I feel like when he locks
in is just over like look at all the n i
mean the nas thing I don't even know how
many Nas albums we've gotten so far it's
been crazy six on record six of them
another Grammy nomination